folks vladimir putin did he walk himself
into a guerrilla war
you know it's one thing to take a city
to take a city like kiev and sadly that
may happen but it's an entirely
different thing to occupy a group of
people that have a strong sense of
national identity who don't want to be
occupied
you have to ask yourself right now that
this guy is this guy sane
i mean seriously as vladimir is vladimir
putin the same person we were dealing
with just six months ago
what calculus was he going through in
his head thinking a city of three
million people with a strong national
identity
an educated group of people
with a long history here armed now the
entire sea three million people many of
them armed did he think taking the city
was going to be as easy as occupying it
did he walk himself into a guerrilla war
here now keep in mind vladimir putin is
a strong man as i said earlier on fox
and friends i didn't say a man who's
strong that's not the same thing he's a
strong man
he requires this patina this mask of of
strength
he needs the illusion the illusion of
stamp what's going to happen when
as he continues to bomb apartment
buildings destroy russian oil excuse me
ukrainian oil depots and the body bags
start to mount up
what happens when he loses support at
home
the russians aren't even polling a
majority in support right now for him
trying to keep ukraine out of nato which
wasn't even on the table
that's the whole thing about strong men
strong men aren't democratically elected
they require this perception of strength
that's going to be slowly cut off at the
knees each and every day as three
million really pissed off ukrainians
start to snipe at these russian soldiers
from apartment buildings in the high
ground inside kiev let me get to my next
guest in a second but i want to bring up
this last point you know in my prior
line of work i did a lot of work on
transportation security now granted it
was not war and i don't mean to compare
it to war
but you are securing the life of the
president united states and your
protectees to secure even a five or six
mile motorcade route you're talking
about hundreds sometimes up to thousands
of people and personnel involved just to
make sure the president can traverse
safely from a to b
vladimir putin thinks he's going to
occupy a city of 3 million people again
with his strong sense of national
identity who don't want him there where
the whole city's high ground and they're
all armed
is he walking himself into a guerrilla
war
he may find out the answer to that the
hard way and one last thing
i strongly encourage him to remember the
words of aeneas
that the victor victor's not victorious
until the vanquish considers himself so
and i strongly doubt the ukrainians
consider themselves vanquished today
tomorrow next week and next year don't
look any better either hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else